you know sometimes something's so
stereotypical that all you want to do is
cry a chiki chaka
he's gonna tame the wild beast like all
true blues know how what if someone
comes to Australia and tries to do that
yeah but he's gonna [ __ ] the bull don't
do that to our wildlife don't think you
can just control them by like but he
made it even worse it's more in the way
than it ever was before
yeah ah I just the boys having fun and
games you see dogs never spilled it
would become pretty W ah the boys I
guess it's not that far away from a lot
of Australian culture like blokey
culture like well let's get drunk and
punch each other this is a way to get a
real reaction out of a bloke and put him
off his game ah could you imagine two
men kissing yuck this big guy wanted to
kill Crocodile Dundee and all you have
to do is give him a beer and
everything's all right mate guess this
is why the world thinks that we're a
bunch of uneducated drunks yeah I mean
we aren't caught some nitwits put two
dummies in e1 dunny one bidet like a
bidet is that the thing where it water
squirts up your ass am i saying all
right bidet good I like g'day but I
might you figure it out the days are
confusing mmm do you stick your whole
body in it if someone's in a different
country you've got no idea what's going
on
the worst thing you have to do is learn
how to use a shower and learn how to use
a toilet this guys [ __ ] clueless and
she says like I'm gonna laugh at him
thank her she's a guy
man dressed up as a girl I already know
where this is heading so god guy dressed
up like a sailor it was a different time
not the best or the most politically
correct thing I've ever seen makes me
feel really sick it's also just bad
writing what do you expect with a movie
so old and so was he the only good thing
about that was that trans woman she was
smokin you got a light buddy yeah sure
kid there you go and your wallet she
knew he was bad cuz he's colored oh
that's a knife how did he even get the
knife through customs oh then this was
before 9/11 and if you're gonna rob a
guy don't rob the guy who is wearing
like crocodiles teeth on his head he
ruined a perfectly good jacket if I was
gonna get mugged I want to be my
personal one as well dressed as him if I
ever had problems sleeping I would watch
this film in the short time that I've
been here I feel like the life has been
sucked out of me
massive props for doing what it did for
Australian Tourism and getting the
Australian culture out there but also
it's playing into this very romanticized
version of Australia white blond
fearless we're trying to be a little bit
more progressive as a country so give us
time it would have been better if it was
a scene like him at a fancy dinner and
they were just like pointing at
different things like that's your salad
fork um that's your knife me like that's
not a knife that's a knife they're like
no that's a that's a dessert spoon hey I
mean like that's a knife they're like
sir that's a plate Nicky you're drunk
again yeah he just makes everything nice